alors c'est bien je viens de travailler
sur en aparté est-ce que ça en aparté ne
répondait pas tu voulais pas l'occasion
de le faire un tri moi qui parle
d altérer les miss sont fantastiques
avec notre salut date est aussi avec
toute l'équipe ici l'autre le petit fils
drogue le petit qui cherche la drogue
dans le plus petit qui se drogue logkii
très bientôt top fils de panis politique
ça et mon attaque 13 qui lie ces
dernières années
vous pensez que j'ai balbutier comme ça
pendant l'émission regardez là je ne
pense pas et c'est certainement vie des
vérités qui vont fait peur un chic qui
vont faire peur à chacun attention il ya
peut-être doute